we have never seen a Silicon Valley
product launch quite like the one on
Friday the CEOs of Apple and Google
released this joint logo signifying
their combined effort to combat the
corona virus next month each company
plans to roll out technology on their
operating systems that can notify
someone if they've been in contact with
the person who's tested positive for
kovat 19 it is called contact tracing
wired editor-in-chief and CBS News
contributor Nick Thompson is here with
details on this Nick a lot of questions
about this first how does it work the
idea is that Apple and Google have made
it possible to run this on top of their
phones you'll download an app probably
from the CDC and there's some other
organization and then and then what will
happen is that you're through bluetooth
it will keep track of all the phone's
that you've been near during the course
of the day so we'll give me a number and
we'll give my parents-in-law in the
other room which within range of my
phone a number those numbers will shift
but over time we'll build a log of every
phone that you've been near for probably
a period of say five minutes
continuously I think everybody will have
a unique number and the data will be
stored on their phone right a lot of
people then what will happen let me just
say it a lot of people have big privacy
concerns about this and one of the
issues here is the is the opt-in part of
it right you you have to opt in if you
want to do this if people aren't opting
in does it still work
yes so you do have to opt in what has to
happen is enough people have to opt in
right cuz if my phone has been near
yours you test positive and you haven't
opted in I don't learn about it because
the system works where when somebody
test positive their phone then tells the
cloud hey I tested positive I have these
numbers the other people then check in
the cloud and say oh have I been near
somebody's positive so if you've been
near someone who has been tested
positive for more than five minutes
you'll get an alert the privacy stuff is
important you won't know who it was
you won't know where it was and if you
haven't tested positive all of your data
stays on the phone
so you're protected that way so it's a
complicated system built in a way to try
to protect your privacy as much as
possible along those lines though Nick
obviously privacy is such a key factor
for so many people who might be able to
access any of that data if it is
collected I know you say it's on your
phone but anyone else that would be able
to get that data well the worrisome
thing is that when you test positive
your data is uploaded to the app whoever
has built the app the data that's being
uploaded is pretty benign it's just a
series of numbers but it will come from
a phone that is based in a location that
is using an IP address so whoever runs
the app would have the ability if they
acted badly to figure out some of the
locations of people who test positive
ideally it's a company that builds a
system in such a way that information is
stripped out and people are protected
but that's the weakness but it is much
better that they've built it this way
than most of the other options that had
much grander weaknesses and obviously at
this point Nick people are just looking
for something to help in this fight we
have Nick Thompson thank you for some
interesting information and insight